تعميق التعاون الامني وتعزيز سياسه الردع
كنا في صلب محادثات الرئيس الامريكي جو
بايدن مع رئيس الوزراء الياباني
فوميوكاشيدا مناسبه لم يفوتها الرئيس بيدن
للتعبير عن موقف بلاده الداعم لليابان مع
تصاعد التوتر حول تايوان وتكثيف في الصين
تحركاتها العسكريه في محيط الجزيره
الامن القومي الجديده الولايات المتحده
ملتزمه بشكل كامل بتحالفها مع اليابان
والاهم من ذلك الدفاع عنها
من جانبه قال رئيس الوزراء الياباني ان
البلدين يواجهان تحديات امنيه تتطلب
التكيف معها
حاليا البيئه الامنيه الاكثر تحديا
وتعقيدا في التاريخ الحديث وضعنا نهايه
العام الماضي استراتيجيه جديده للامن
القومي من اجل ضمان السلام والازدهار في
المنطقه الى جانب الحفاظ على الامن في
اليابان
[موسيقى]
هي الصين وكوريا الشماليه وحرب روسيا في
اوكرانيا وبينما 9 طوكيو الى تعزيز
قدراتها الدفاعيه والهجوميه تحاول واشنطن
تعزيزه وجودها العسكري في اليابان على
واقع تخوف من غزونين محتمل النساء وفي هذا
السياق قال خلصت اجتماعات اللجنه
الامريكيه اليابانيه الى توسيع نطاق
المعاهده الامنيه لتشمل الفضاء الخارجيه
لصد ايه هجمات على الاقمار الصناعيه
المرتبطه بالانظمه الدفاعيه عنها
الى الصين على انها تهديد الرئيسي
للولايات المتحده على المدى الطويل لذا
فان الخططه والقدرات والانشطه الامريكيه
كل مصممه لمواجهه التهديدات المحتمله من
الصين ضد اليابان والتايوان وتاتي
المباحثات الامريكيه اليابانيه بعد صدور
الاستراتيجيه الدفاعيه اليابانيه المحدثه
التي تتضمن زياده غير مسبوقه في حجم
الانفاق الدفاعي بنسبه جعلتها ثالثه قوه
عسكريه من حيث معدل الانفاق بعد الولايات
المتحده والصين كما تزامنت مع اعلان
البحريه الامريكيه وصول حامله الطائرات
نمت الى بحر جنوب الصين لاجراء تمرينات
عسكريه
التوجه الامريكي والياباني من الصين برز
بعد رفض وزير الدفاع الصيني تلقي مكالمه
من نظيره الامريكيه الاثنين الماضيه على
اثر اعتراضي تيار صيني طائره امريكيه فوق
بحر جنوب الصين وتامل الاداره الامريكيه
ان تساهم زياره وزير الخارجيه الامريكي
لبجين المزرعه هذا الشهر في نضعه التوتر
وجع في الجزيره البيت الابيض واشنطن